a story that has caused diplomatic and
security reverberations right around the
world ended today in a Massachusetts a
rural part of Massachusetts where as you
say there's 21 year old
um Airman from the Massachusetts
Massachusetts Air National Guard was
detained at his mother's home the images
are extraordinary in themselves they
show uh the uh heavily armed FBI
officials behind an armored vehicle
which had been driven up the street uh
was they then called uh up to the house
we're told that he came out Jack Tashira
came out voluntarily from his mother's
house he was then guided back walking
backwards to the left of that armored
vehicle as they um pointed their weapons
at him he was then his arms were then
lowered he was handcuffed and he has now
been taken away for questioning